Apple's M3 iPad Pro is coming as soon as
this March and it's going to be the
biggest iPad Pro redesign ever even
bigger than the incredible flat redesign
back in 2018 that changed tablets
forever and just a few days ago we got a
huge new leak from Mac Rumors saying
that we should pretty much be expecting
Apple's Mac safe wireless charging
feature to come to the new iPad Pro
which seems like it doesn't really make
sense on something like an iPad but it
actually does so I'm going to explain
everything in this video but first I
want to give a quick shout out to our
sponsor Tu buddy which we've been using
for years on this channel to boost our
earnings and add Revenue using two
buddies mini analytics and video
optimization tools like AB testing with
titles and thumbnails their keyboard
Explorer tool for SEO optimization their
thumbnail analyzer tool and much more so
use code Max te30 for 30% off Tu buddy
by using the link in the description
below to sign up thank you too buddy for
sponsoring this video way back in June
of 2021 Mark German came out with a
shocking new leak that didn't make any
sense at that time apparently the next
iPad Pro would be coming with both
wireless charging and reverse wireless
charging capabilities which means that
the iPad Pro would be able to recharge
other devices like airpods the Apple
watch and even an iPhone using Max safe
magnets right on the back of the iPad Ad
Pro and yes that's not just me saying it
those are literally words from Mark
German adding that Apple was considering
giving the iPad an entire glass back in
order to enable wireless charging since
it obviously doesn't work through the
current metal back but then there were a
bunch of concerns about it being too
fragile cracking and shattering which
makes perfect sense so Mark also warned
that the project could end up getting
cancelled before 202 2 well January of
2022 came along and 95 Mac reported that
Apple hid a roadblock in its plans to
redesign the iPad Pro with Max safe
wireless charging and they have most
likely scrapped the rumored glassback
redesign sources familiar with 95 Mac
said that Apple was uncertain about the
glass since it's easier to damage so
apparently One Source claimed that Apple
developed prototypes of the iPad Pro
with a larger apple look logo made out
of glass in order to house the maxfe
wireless charging system while retaining
the metal back basically the best of
both designs and then in both March and
June Mark griman once again doubled down
on a new iPad Pro with Max safe wireless
charging and an M2 Chip now narrowing
down the release date to October which
is when it finally was released but
unfortunately we got basically the most
disappointing iPad Pro update possible
there was no redesign at all no camera
upgrades no Mac safe no nothing it was
literally the same iPad Pro but with the
M2 Chip and a couple of small software
features like hover for the apple pencil
so my theory from the very beginning was
that Apple chose to delay the redesign
that we were supposed to get until the
next iteration and they simply gave us a
stop Gap product update and I still
believe this to be true today and that's
why I believe all of those Max safe
charging rumors are real but they were
simply DeLay So then came more news
about a new iPad Pro coming in 2024 with
an M3 chip a new thinner design and the
best display ever put into a tablet with
dual OLED panels that would create the
best of both worlds beautiful contrast
and colors while still being insanely
bright with no halo effect like we
currently have on the mini LED display
iPad Pro and then that finally brings us
to the brand new leak that we just got
from Mac Rumors who have a new source
that is familiar with companies that
manufacture magnets for Apple products
and they claim that this upcoming iPad
Pro could be coming with Max safe
wireless charging support so just as we
thought all hope was lost for max if
wireless charging on the iPad Pro we're
starting to hear more more and more
confirmation about this actually coming
and it would totally make sense if this
Max sa redesign that Mark Gman confirmed
over and over again was in fact delayed
at the last minute back in 2022 destined
for the next update which is coming in
March of 2024 and if you think that's
all the evidence I have for Mac safe
coming to the iPad it's not we have a
bunch of leaks concerning the brand new
magic keyboard 2 coming alongside the
new iPad Pro and we have a lot of
evidence for this also coming with Mac
safe back in August Mark Gman leaked
that a new redesigned magic keyboard
would accompany the new iPad Pro making
it look more like a laptop than the
current setup by having a larger
trackpad which is a great idea because
the current one is very small and very
limiting and then in September he gave
us some more details claiming that the
magic keyboard would feature an alumin
top case with the area around the
keyboard itself being made out of
aluminum resembling what a Macbook looks
like to provide a sturdier structure and
more premium design however only half of
it would be made out of aluminum because
the exterior shell of the keyboard would
retain the same silicon cover material
as we have now and if you're wondering
why only half of it would be aluminum
instead of making the whole thing
aluminum well to me that's an even
bigger piece of evidence that points to
Max safe wireless charging being built
into the top silicon half so it
perfectly matches up to all of the leaks
so the top portion would essentially
have a double stacked Max safe module so
if you attached a Max saafe charger on
the back it would pass through charge to
the iPad Pro itself or it would also
allow reverse wireless charging for
other devices that are attached to the
back of the magic keyboard case charging
from the iPad Pro and if you think
that's too hard to believe Apple
actually filed for a bunch of patents
that point to exactly this this patent
here points to a redesigned magic
keyboard 2 with a built-in apple pencil
recharging slot and a double hinge that
would allow you to use it in a new
clipboard mode which the current one
doesn't support but in terms of Max safe
support back in 2021 Apple filed for a
patent for an entire wireless charging
ecosystem for the MacBook iPad iPhone
and Apple watch which explains an
electronic device including an alignment
magnet that is positioned adjacent to
the inductive coil configured to assist
in positioning the external device
relative to the electronic device which
is obviously explaining Mac safe which
after this patent filing did come to the
Apple watch and since wireless charging
Mac safe is not going to work on a metal
MacBook Pro we know that this patent was
actually intended for the iPad and guess
what patent filing we just got in June
of this year an iPad with inductive
charging coils behind the display to
charge devices now their patents were
really weird showing off a huge array of
coils which doesn't really make any
sense at all except for the one image
that showed a single coil in the center
with a patent text describing it
recharging devices like an Apple Watch a
smartphone or portable media player
which is obviously airpods so everything
is finally coming together but there's
one last patent that's the nail in the
coffin here this patent from 2021
explains a new magic keyboard that will
be able to recharge an iPhone Apple
watch and more coming with not one but
two wireless power coils with charged
device is being held in place using
magnets or Mac safe and while the image
doesn't make any sense at all it doesn't
have to because this is actually a
Utility Patent and not a design patent
so the location of the coils can be
moved around without issues so now we
have tons of evidence for Mac safe being
built into not just the iPad Pro but
also the new magic keyboard and based on
everything else we've covered in this
video I'm very confident that the
upcoming iPad Pro will support wireless
Mac safe charging so hopefully you enjoy
this video and if you did you can
subscribe above and definitely check out
one of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next
[Music]
one